[Музика]
привіт всім, настав час уроку англійської мови
мене звати Наталія Шолл давайте
сьогодні почнемо ми закінчимо тему кіно
і поговоримо про фільми тому останній
урок сьогодні і ми збираємося написати
огляд фільму давайте так це наш  завдання
подивіться тут, нам потрібно написати короткий
огляд для англійського журналу вашої школи
про використання фільму на DVD, тому вам
потрібно написати від 50 до 100 слів у
вашому огляді, вам потрібно вказати назву
та тип фільму, який вам потрібно дати
короткий підсумок сюжету, і вам потрібно
порекомендувати фільм, тож давайте розглянемо
питання, перше запитання, що
ви збираєтеся написати відповідно до
рубрики, тож ми пишемо електронну пошту чи запис у
блозі, зараз ми пишемо огляд фільму,
тож хто  збирається читати подивіться
на текст знайдіть інформацію,
огляд фільму прочитають
читачі англійського журналу, давайте розберемося з
номером три, що ви повинні включити у
свій огляд, і це інформація,
яка згадується в рубриці, яку вам
потрібно  напишіть назву та тип фільму,
короткий опис сюжету та вашу
рекомендацію, давайте подивимося на
останнє питання, скільки слів ви повинні
написати, щоб від 50 до 100 це ваш
кадр, давайте рухатися далі,
це приклад модель для вас, і
ми  потрібно зіставити абзаци із
заголовками, тому я даю вам десять секунд, щоб
переглянути текст, і ми збираємося
написати останній з їхніх абзаців,
давайте перевіримо, щоб перший з яких вам
сподобався фільм і ваша рекомендація,
де ця інформація абзац a B
або C правильна відповідь: C подивитись
Месники — це справді захоплюючий фільм із
безліччю насичених екшеном сцен, 3D-
спеціальні ефекти також фантастичні, ви
відчуваєте, що перебуваєте в центрі дійства,
це потрібно подивитися, тож давайте з
друге питання, де назва і
тип фільму, а де актори, де це
особняк, параграф A або B, а правильна
відповідь: давайте
подивимось Месники — це бойовик про шістьох
популярних супергероїв,
режисером якого виступив Дж.  Осса Уідона та
зіркового акторського складу Роберта Дауні-молодшого.
грає роль залізної людини, а Кріс
Еванс починає роль Капітана Америки, а
останній короткий опис сюжету - відповідь
B, тому світ знаходиться в небезпеці, коли
злий Локі планує його знищити Нік
Ф'юрі, голова міжнародної
поліцейської організації, збирає
команда супергероїв для боротьби з аніме,
тому для вас буде завдання,
давайте поговоримо про різні вирази,
які ми можемо використовувати
для опису фільму, їх існує величезна
кількість,
тож давайте подивимось навколо, це розповідає
історію, не пропустіть  це зірки, оскільки сюжет дуже
захоплюючий тощо.
був режисером і
має чудовий акторський склад, а останній —
це пригодницький або бойовик, чи
історична комедія чи фільм жахів, тому ми
наведемо тип фільму, а тепер розділимо всі
ці фрази на три категорії, тож
почнемо з  перша група ми
збираємося описати передісторію
фільму або фільму давайте почнемо, що ми можемо
використовувати для опису на задньому плані, це
розповідає історію, тому повторюйте за мною, це
розповідає історію добра, давайте перейдемо
до наступної найбільшої фрази  і
це мій улюблений, тому що це
найпростіший, тож це пригодницький фільм
або бойовик, це історичний
фільм, це фільм жахів або це
комедія.
має чудову вартість, тому
повторюйте за мною режисером і
має чудовий акторський склад, хороші зірки, тому він або
вона дайте ім'я актора, який знімає нам
це зірки, і ще раз, коли він знімається, давайте
перейдемо далі, мм-хм, розклад вистави
грає роль знову ви вказуєте
ім'я людини і кажете грає роль
і ви даєте ім'я персонажа,
тепер давайте поговоримо про загальні коментарі, тому
ми закінчили з фоном, давайте перейдемо
до загальних коментарів про фільм і
тут  можна сказати, акторський
склад знову чудовий  акторський склад чудовий Браво,
давайте продовжимо спецефекти
ще раз приголомшливі
спецефекти приголомшливі гарна
робота сюжет захоплюючий або сюжет
захоплюючий, якщо вам не подобається фільм,
можна сказати, що сюжет нудний, тому просто
використовуйте  різні прикметники
давайте спробуємо ще раз сюжет захоплюючий
дякую
давайте рухаємося далі це дивовижний фільм з
і ще раз дякую, тому ми закінчуємо
рекомендацією, звичайно, очевидно,
що все інше стосується
рекомендацій, але давайте повторимо
слова не пропустіть  це знову не пропустіть
у фільмі належного стану,
це варто знову побачити
наступний я дуже рекомендую його ще раз я
дуже рекомендую його,
дякую, і давайте зосередимося на цій фразі
це мій улюблений, він дуже соковитий  це
обов'язково буде касовим хітом це
обов'язково буде касовим хітом, тож як ми можемо
перекласти цю фразу, коли фіктивна обкладинка
star nickytom добре, тож вся корисна
мова для вас тут, ви можете взяти
свій телефон так  ea picture та
запам'ятайте слова, тому що вони знадобляться
вам, поки ви збираєтеся писати огляд,
давайте, щоб ми отримали інформацію
від танків про Месників, а
тепер давайте перефразуємо фрази
добре, так що давайте, маємо зірковий акторський склад,
як можна  ми перефразуємо це акторський склад —
чудова можлива відповідь, давайте з
номером два — це дійсно захоплюючий фільм, тому
це дивовижний фільм, це також
можливо, спеціальні ефекти приголомшливі,
приголомшливий — дуже гарне слово, використовуйте його,
пам'ятайте та використовуйте, це потрібно
подивитися  не пропустіть це також можливо добре,
тому зараз є завдання для вас
подивіться, у нас є п'ять речень, і вони
хочуть, щоб ви вибрали правильне слово, я
даю вам десять секунд переглянути, а
потім ми збираємося перевірити разом, тому
готовий перевірити давайте підемо
номер один історія має трагічний та/або
налаштування того, що буде правильно,
історія має трагічний кінець номер два
акторський склад жахливий або повільний правильна
відповідь жахливий акторський склад жахливий номер три
він збережеться  ви на краю свого
сидіння або цікавитеся, яка правильна
відповідь, і це також дуже гарна
фраза, тому давайте повторимо разом,
вона буде тримати вас на краю вашого
сидіння, і знову це буде тримати вас на
краю вашого місця  Ну, тоді номер
чотири актори дають блискучу гру
або блискучу режисуру, що є
правильною відповіддю,
тому скажімо ще раз,
актори дають блискучу гру,
молодці, а під номером п'ять саундтрек
фантастичний або насичений екшн так, фантастичний,
саундтрек фантастичний, я сподіваюся  що
всі ваші відповіді правильні, тож
продовжимо ми поговоримо про прикметники
, щоб описати фільм, які
прикметники ви можете використовувати цікаво
фантастичне приголомшливо що ще
нудно нудно захоплююче захоплююче
давайте подивимося на завдання, які у нас є навантаження
прикметників тут так як ви бачите
цікавий і цікавий або повний сумний
нудний невигадливий власний противний що
це означає противний противний неприємний давайте
бідолашний повільний di  дивовижний або злий
фантастичний сильний дивовижний талановитий
красивий несподіваний так що може бути
несподіваним несподіваний кінець наприклад
те, чого ви не очікуєте
розумного захоплюючого відмінного, тому давайте
замінимо пункти жирним шрифтом і виберемо
для них правильну відповідь давайте
подивимося,
акторський склад хороший  фраза окей, вона
не неправильна, але ми можемо використовувати різні
прикметники, щоб показати, що наша мова
справді багата давайте йти акторський склад
чудовий це бойові слова давайте
йти з номером два сценарій в порядку,
тому сценарій розумний це гарне слово
несподіваний може йти до кінця, але не
про сценарій, давайте з номером
три, сюжет гарний, тому знову
замість гарного цікавого або красивого
цікавого молодець номер чотири
спецефекти гарні, ми любимо
слово добре, і вони знають, що ви любите
це слово  також добре, але давайте розширимо
наш горизонт і використаємо різні фрази,
щоб спецефекти були дивовижними,
давайте рухатися на движку добре, тому
фінал  фантастично
це Берта фантастичний номер шість
акторський склад поганий, тому замість того, щоб сказати
негативні прикметники погано, що ми можемо
сказати, жахливий номер сім сценарій поганий,
тому сценарій нудний це також
можливо або нудний номер вісім
сюжет поганий  уявний також можливий
тут сюжет не уявний номер
дев'ять спецефекти погані, тому у
нас добре, а тут у нас погані, тому ми можемо
сказати, що спецефекти погані, нас
не цікавлять, і останній
кінець поганий або кінцівка
розчаровує, тому, як ви бачите, якщо ви подивитеся
на це зображення, у нас є дві колонки:
позитивний і негативний акторський склад
хороший акторський склад поганий, краще сказати, акторський склад
чудовий, акторський склад жахливий, у цьому
випадку ви збираєтеся продемонструвати, що
ваш словниковий запас дуже сильний, тому
уривки добре, що сценарій поганий
знову, щоб покращити, ви можете сказати,
що сценарій розумний або сценарій
нудний і те саме з сюжетом і
спецефектами та  закінчуючи зараз, давайте
розглянемо різні фрази, щоб
рекомендувати фільм таким позитивним і негативним, і
давайте створимо два полюси, позитивний пух
і негативний полюс. Я збираюся написати
фрази на дошці, і ви можете писати
зі мною.
позитивний я збираюся використовувати зелений
колір для позитиву,
тому позитивний, фільм варто
подивитися, позитивний він чи негативний
позитивний, тож давайте добре запишемо будь-які
інші позитивні фрази, які
потрібно подивитися, не пропустіть їх  інші фрази
виглядають не пори це побачать, хм,
схоже на негатив все інше, ви
повинні побачити це, якщо у вас є шанс,
це також позитивно.
Гаразд, давайте з негативними фразами, тож
це повна трата часу,
тому залишиться з багатими зображеннями
Хороший номер чотири не турбуйся
зараз подивитись, Вітні робить потужні розбіжності,
врятуй його
добре, і останній, який ти
обов'язково повинен дати цьому фільму Міс Маучер,
Славко пропагував safing
добре, так що просто пам'ятайте, щоб
позитивно  щоб командувати полем, ви можете
використовувати фільм, це добре, ми бачимо, що це
милосердя.
подивіться, або вам
неодмінно варто заплутати цей фільм,
тож давайте рухатимемося вперед, ось наше завдання
знову, ми збираємося написати короткий
огляд, і у нас є згадана інформація,
тому знову ж таки, що ми збираємося
написати огляд, хто збирається  прочитайте його,
читачі англомовного
журналу, і яку інформацію ви повинні
вказати назву фільму типу
фільму, короткий опис сюжету та
вашу рекомендацію та останній,
скільки абзаців ви повинні написати,
подивіться, щоб нам було потрібно  згадайте три
частини інформації, тож три абзаци давайте
розглянемо, коли нам потрібно написати
щось, ми починаємо з мозкового штурму,
і павук Грем може нам допомогти, тож ви
напишете в середині фільму або
назву свого фільму, і ви підете з
усіма  інформація н  eeded
рекомендація спецефектів ім'я Клод тип режисер
і акторський склад подивіться на цей, тож як
називається фільм, швидко знайдіть цю
інформацію так, Воскресіння темного лицаря,
який тип фільму цей супергеройський
бойовик хороший хто режисер
Крістофер Нолан  хто акторський склад
Крістіан Бейл і Майкл Кейн, добре, так
що це потрібно подивитися, а
спецефекти дивовижні, тому, якщо вам
не подобається павук Грем, ви можете просто
використовувати такі нотатки, щоб записати
їх у свій блокнот, а я  збираюся
написати свою особисту інформацію, тому мені подобаються
фільми про Гаррі Поттера, тому напишіть відгук про
фільм про Гаррі Поттера, допоможіть мені з
інформацією, тому назва фільму Гаррі
Поттер,
так що фільми про Гаррі Поттера, скільки фільмів у
нас вже є, є вісім
добре зроблених фільмів  тип фільму Я думаю,
що це фантастичний фільм
, ви згодні з режисером, тому
різні фільми про Гаррі Поттера мають
різних режисерів, тож давайте зосередимося
на першому та другому, і т  він
режисер Христофор Колумб добре
Кріс Колумб, тому режисер
Кріс Колумбус, давайте перейдемо до сюжету,
тому коротке резюме сюжету - це хлопчик, який
дізнався, що він чарівник, пішов
до школи чарівників і бореться
зі злом  Тож як
звали злого, якого не можна назвати,
молодець, так що спецефекти
приголомшливі та рекомендації, хм, це має бути
зрозуміло, це добре слово.
план,
який ви маєте пам’ятати, у вас є три
абзаци, абзац перший, назва та
тип режисера-режисера, а також акторський
абзац номер два, сюжет і
абзац номер три загальні коментарі
чи рекомендації, щоб ви могли використовувати цей
кадр, щоб написати рецензію після того, як
ви закінчите  написання пройдіть
контрольний список, коли ви закінчите писати свою
перевірку на рецензію. Нижче наведено їх
добре структуровані параграфи, чи включили ви
всі пункти в рубрику
, чи використовували ви різноманітні прикметники, якщо у
вас занадто багато wo  rds як добре
перефразуйте їх змініть їх чи
є орфографічні або граматичні
помилки попередній перегляд підказка зонд опус пункту
пунктуація подати в суд на новий вірш Ермітажу
добре, чи це в межах обмеження слів,
підрахуйте слова пам'ятайте, що нам потрібно залишатися
в кадрі від 50 до 100 слів і якщо
вам потрібно внести будь-які необхідні зміни,
перш ніж передати його вчителю, тому
ми будемо слухати огляд фільму,
поки ви слухаєте, заповнюючи прогалини The
Dark Knight Rises — супергеройський
бойовик про останні Пригоди
Бетмена, режисер Крістофер
Нолан  і має чудовий акторський
склад Крістіана Бейла, а Бетмен і Майкл Кейн грають роль його
дворецького і близького друга. Сюжет
захоплюючий.
Готем-Сіті знову в небезпеці, тому що
там так багато злочинів, що Бетмен вирішує, що
йому доведеться битися ще раз, щоб захистити
людей  але вони думають, що він їхній ворог.
The Dark Knight Rises — це фільм із
чудовим екшеном та приголомшливими
спецефектами, який обов’язково потрібно подивитися, не пропустіть його,
тому давайте перевіримо Темний  «Лицар Воскресіння»
— це правильна відповідь
супергеройський бойовик про останні
пригоди Бетмена,
це ммм-хмм від Крістофера Нолана, він
був добре зроблений і має
чудовий акторський склад, зірки Крістіана Бейла, а
роль Бетмена і Майкла Кейна грають
Батлер і близький друг молодець
номер шість покращення захоплююче
що
захоплює сюжет захоплює Готем-сіті знову в
небезпеці, тому що там так багато
злочинів, Бетмен вирішує, що йому доведеться битися
ще раз, щоб захистити людей, але вони
думають, що він їхній ворог  Отже, «Темний
лицар Воскресіння» — це фільм із чудовими екшенами
та приголомшливими спецефектами, це
милосердя, не пропустіть його
добре, тому ваше домашнє завдання для наступного
уроку, хлопці, вам потрібно написати коротку
рецензію для вашого шкільного англійського журналу
про фільм, який ви бачили  на DVD, тому не
забудьте ще раз згадати важливу
інформацію,
назва типу фільму, дайте короткий
зміст сюжету та ваші рекомендації та
скільки слів 50 до 100 і вони h
гра в дзвіночок, що означає, що нам
потрібно припинити урок, дуже дякую
і побачимося наступного разу,
[Музика]